pas de travaux est particulièrement
difficile milieu des années 60
le québec est en pleine ébullition la
firme lavalin est chargée de la
construction du pont tunnel louis
hippolyte lafontaine pour l'époque
c'est une prouesse d'ingénierie du côté
de snc le défi c'est le barrage
daniel-johnson et la centrale manic 5 et
encore aujourd'hui demeure le barrage à
voûtes le plus élevé au monde
deux firmes rivales qui symbolise le
savoir-faire du génie québécois début
des années 90 laval est en sérieuse
difficulté 1991 c'est la fusion snc
absorbe lavalin
c'est la naissance d'un géant si en 1991
entreprises ne génère que 12 millions de
dollars en profits en 2008
le bénéfice net grimpe à 312 millions
snc lavalin devient une des plus grosses
sociétés du genre dans le monde
au départ l'entreprise comptait moins de
6000 employés
aujourd'hui c'est plus de 50000 répartis
dans 35 pays
environ 3400 travail au québec sur
d'importants projets comme le nouveau
rêve et le futur pont champlain à
montréal
mais derrière les ambitions se cachent
des histoires de corruption
ici il y a le centre universitaire de
santé mcgill les plus hauts dirigeants
plaident coupable dans cette affaire
qualifiée de plus grosse fraude par
corruption de l'histoire canadienne
pendant dix ans et laura ailleurs il ya
le dossier libyen cette fois c'est
l'entreprise elle-même qui fait face à
des accusations criminelles
une condamnation pourrait priver snc
lavalin de contrats publics écoulée pour
de bon la société voilà maintenant que
s'ajoute un autre possibles stratagèmes
de corruption entourant cette fois le
contrat de réfection du pont
jacques-cartier ici vincent maisonneuve
radio canada montréal